اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر من كل ومن جميع الجوانب
نتنياهو يقرر منع اقتحامات المستوطنين
للاقصى في الايام العشره الاخيره من رمضان
يحذر من التصعيد
اليوم الخميس يوم 13 من هذا الشهر اول يوم
سوف يكون هنالك عمليه تبادل بين صنعاء
وعدن وسط ترحيب اممي الحكومه اليمنيه تعلن
عن تبادل الاسرع مع الحوثيين الخميس ويشمل
رحلات طيران بين عدن وصنعه
محتاجون يهاجمون ماكرون في لهايه يقاطعون
كلمته ويصفونه برئيس العنف والنفاق
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
اذا كنت تمتلك سياره تسلا فاحذر انت مراقب
بكاميرات سياره الداخليه والخارجيه تقرير
يوفق نشر لحظات حساسه
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
المستوطنين لحرم المسجد الاقصى حتى نهايه
شهر رمضان ونقلت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه
عن وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن خسير
اعتراضه على القرار مؤكدا انه سيزيد من
تصعيد الموقف على حد قوله ياتي ذلك فيما
تتواصل اقتحامات المستوطنين لباحات المسجد
الاقصى تحت حراسه الشرطه الاسرائيليه وذلك
على دفعات تقتحم المسجد عبر باب المغاربه
وتخرج عبر باب السلسله
[موسيقى]
والجيش الاسرائيلي نشر منظومات دفاع جوي
اضافيه في عده مناطق بعد التوترات الاخيره
وفقا للاعلام الاسرائيليه على كل يبقى
معنا من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه هناك
زياد حلبي في تفاصيل على هذا الموضوع قبل
ان اعود الى موضوع الباحات المسجد الاقصى
زياد
لا طبعا هذا القرار هو فقط من يتخذه رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل وليس وزير الامن القومي ولا
وزير الدفاع ولا اي وزير اخر وبالتالي كان
معروفا بان نتنياهو سيتخذ هذا القرار
بطبيعه الحال يبدو القرار لافتا بسبب ان
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه الاخيره على
المعتكفين في المسجد الاقصى كانت فجر كل
التصعيد الذي نتحدث عنه في الايام الاخيره
في كل الجبهات في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
قطاع غزه لبنان سوريا اخيرا ايضا
وبالتالي لهذا يبدو لافتا ولكن في حقيقه
الامر بان هذا القرار بات تقليديا بمعنى
كل سنه في السنوات الاخيره العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان تمنع الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه
من قبل المستوطنين المتطرفين لساحات
المسجد الاقصى ويسمح الاعتكاف في المسجد
القبلي طوال ساعات الليل وفي الصباح ايضا
بالتالي هذا ليس جديدا لكن بدون ان شك بان
هناك الان خلاف شديد بين نتنياهو وبين
جزير الوزير الاكثر تطرفا في هذه الحكومه
والذي طبعا خرج بموقف يهاجم نتنياهو يقول
ان هذا القرار يعتبر ضعفا اسرائيليا وانه
لن يؤدي الى هدوء بل سيؤدي الى المزيد من
اتساع لدوامه العنف كما سماها في داخل
الاسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال هناك اهميه
للمؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه اكثر من كلام
بنكفير المؤسسه الامنيه كانت ايضا منقسمه
على نفسها جزء منها كان يؤيد استمرار
الاقتحامات لكن الشرطه الاسرائيليه حسمت
الامر قالت لنتنياهو انها ترى تصعيدا
دراماتيكيا اذا ما استمرت لاقتحامات في
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان ولهذا اتخذ
هذا القرار ولكن لنفهم اكثر زياد عندما
يقول بن جيران وهذا سيؤدي الى تصعيد
الموقف اكثر ويعترض على مثل هذا القرار
هل يعني انه هذا غير مطمئن بمعنى انه
الحظر قد يكون حبرا على ورق ذلك الذي فرضه
نتنياهو رغم رغم كل المحاولات التي ربما
يقوم بها فعلا
لا لا يستطيع بن جبير ان يفرض على الشرطه
الاسرائيليه هذه مثل هذه القرارات هذا
القرار
متعارف عليه في اسرائيل بانه قمه الهرم في
المستوى السياسي تتخذه وليس وزيرا
وبالتالي ليس لديه ادوات لتخريب هذا
القرار على الارض باستثناء هذه التصريحات
وهذا التصعيد الكلامي المعروف عنه يعني
واضح جدا شكرا جزيلا لك زياد حلبي مراسل
مدير مكتب العربيه في القدس
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه بدات عمليات تبادل
الاسرى والمعتقلين مع الحوثيين الخميس
المقبل ولمده ثلاثه ايام واشار الفريق
الحكومي بالمفاوضات لان عمليات تبادل
الاسرى ستشمل رحلات جويه بين العاصمه
صنعاء وعددا ومناطق اخرى في اليمن
بالتنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر
كما اكد ان الاستعدادات اكتملت
اليوم الاول وهو طبعا كان المقرر في يوم
عشره وتم تاجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام
بسبب الاجراءات طبعا التي اخذت وقت نظرا
لعدد الكبير عدد الذين من سوف يتم
مبادلتهم تم تاجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام
اليوم الاول سوف يكون
بحسب ما اتفق عليه
يوم طبعا بعد غدا يوم الخميس يوم 13 من
هذا الشهر اول يوم سوف يكون هنالك عمليه
تبادل بين صنعاء وعدن 250 عصير ومختطف
قال المبعوث الاماميه لليمن في تصريحات
لوكاله رويترز ان المحدثات العميقه
والجاده بين الاطراف اليمنيه امر مشجع
واضاف انه يعمل مع جميع الاطراف لضمان ان
هذه الجود هود تدعم وساطه الامم المتحده
وينضم الينا من الرياض عرفات حمران رئيس
نظمت راست للحقوق والحريات في اليمن اهلا
بك سيد عرفات يعني حول صفقه تبادل الاسرى
هذه هل من تفاصيل اكثر حول يعني الترتيبات
الترتيبات يوم الخميس الاعداد اعداد
الاسرى هم اغلبهم معروف انه من المدنيين
طبعا ملف الاسرى هو طريق الجيد لاحلال اي
سلام باليمن كونه ملف انساني بحث وايضا
يؤسس لحوار جاد وحسن نيه من قبل الحوثيين
والشرعيه بما يخص يعني اطلاق المختطفين
وبدء عمليه سلام حقيقيه يوم الخميس القادم
هو اول ايام تبادل الاسرى والتي ستكون
هناك طائرات تتحرك من صنعاء الى عدن ومن
عدن ونفسها تعود الى الى صنعاء هناك 73
مختطف اسير سيتم تبادلهم من بينهم وزير
الدفاع السابق
وايضا شقيق الرئيس هادي
وهذه هي اول عمليه ستبدا من بعد ذلك اليوم
الثاني والثالث الجمعه والسبت سيكون هناك
ايضا تحرك في سته مطارات هي مارب وعدن
وايضا وابها
وعدن وسيكون هناك 887
مختطف يقوم تبادلهم مقابل 181 ايضا مختطف
واسير من الشرعيه وبذلك تكون انتهت عمليه
تبادل الاسرى التي كان الحوار من اجلها
وتبدا عمليه ثانيه في منتصف الشهر القادم
ربما تكون الكل مقابل الكل ويغلق ملف
الاسرع وتصفر عمليه
الاختطافات والاعتقالات بين بين الطرفين
وتبدا ايضا عمليه اخرى هي عمليه ايضا صرف
الرواتب وافتاح المنافذ وايضا بموضوع
الحقوق والحريات استاذ عرفات اذا سمحت لي
هل في ظل هذا الجو الذي فيه عدد من
الاطراف
الاساسيين على الاقل يريد استقرارا يريد
سلاما يريد انهاء لسنوات الحرب ان صح هذا
الكلام على جميع الاطراف المعنيه كما تقول
حتى الان على الاقل هل بالامكان الحديث عن
محاسبه عن عداله انتقاليه على الاقل ان لم
يكن هناك مجال لمحاسبه بالمعنى القانوني
والقضائي الكامل
طبعا لابد هناك ان نعرف ان هناك حقوق عامه
وحقوق خاصه ربما الحقوق الخاص العامه سيتم
هناك عفو شامل لكن باللغه الاسباني الحقوق
الخاصه سيشمل ذلك عمليه العداله الانتقالي
والعدل الانتقاليه لليمنيين لدينا قانون
في هذه العداله الانتقاليه اسس في 2012
الحوار الوطني هذه العمليه ستخضع لمعايير
ثلاثه بالنسبه لاذا اردنا ان ندخل بعمليه
السلام وعمليه محاسبه اولا ممكن ان يحدث
هناك ان يتقدم اي من مرتكبي انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان بالاعتراف بذنبهم واستراد ما تم
انتهائه هذا الجانب الامر الثاني ستحدث
هناك معالجه وتعويض مادي ومعنوي بمعنى جبر
ضرر للضحايا وهذا ربما تقوم به
اطراف يعني
التحالف واطراف ايضا داعمه اخرى بعمليه
دبر الضرر العمليه الثالثه في قانون
العداله الانتقاليه سينص على انه من حق
الضحايا الوصول الى المحاكم اذا لم يتم
هناك اي مصالحه ولم يقتنعوا تعويضات لكن
اليمنيين دائما متسامعين وربما في هذا
المجال سنه يعني سيكون هناك نماذج جيد من
اجل ان يسود اليمن سلام عادل يكفي ثمان
سنوات حروب
ولا اعتقد ان احد نعم ماذا عن المخفيين
والمغيبين قصرا يعني هناك اشخاص
تم اختطافهم واعتقالهم منذ تسع سنوات وحتى
الان لا معلومات يعني هل هؤلاء هل سيتم
الحديث بموضوعهم هناك معلومات للاهالي
والاسر
طبعا كل المخفيين يعني والمختطفين الذين
قاعده بيانات وهناك ايضا تحركات لكن
الواضح فعلا انه نحن نعرف من الجهه التي
قامت باختطافهم مثل ان الحوثيقه لكن
الحوثيين ينكرون او يخفون ذلك العمليه
التي تكون بعد شهر في منتصف شوال القادم
ستشمل كل المختطفين وربما لن يحدث هناك اي
مختطف ولا اسير في سجل مختطفين هناك
نيه لاقفال هذا المرض وتصفير هذا العداد
ولن يستثني هذا الموضوع احد اذا هناك جهود
اقليميه ودوليه من اجل انهاء هذا الملف
وبدء بمرحله جديده لليمنيين ينعمون ربما
بسلام ولن يحدث هناك اي يعني
ضرر طالما هناك ايضا جبر وتعويضات
للضحايا واسرهم شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا سيد عرفات حمران رئيس
منظمه رصد للحقوق والحريه في اليمن تحياتي
اليك
صنعت الجهود الدبلوماسيه الاخيره والحراك
السياسي في المنطقه تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده
سمتها الاستقرار وتغريب المصالح على
الصراع السياسي والعسكري نتابع
حراك سياسي قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المتوتره على كثير من الجبهات لاطفاء كثير
من الحرائق التي ظلت مشتعله لسنوات
عاد الضوء الى طاولات الحوار بدءا بتهدئه
التوتر بين عدد من دول المنطقه وتركيه
مرورا بلقاءات بين القيادات السياسيه
وانتهاء بالاتفاق مع انقره على ايجاد سبل
لحل الملفات او تهدئه حده الصراع في سوريا
وليبيا
العاشر من مارس شهد ايضا ولاده لاتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه بعد قطيعه
امتدت لنحو سبع سنوات اعطت املا بظهور
نتائج ايجابيه على ملفات عده بالمنطقه
كسوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن الخطوه
الاخيره في سلسله التهدئه جاءت من اليمن
بعد زياره وفدي السعوديه وعمان لصنعاء
ولقائهما بقياده الحوثيين وبحث الوصول الى
الحل السياسي عبر عده مراحل يؤمل منها
اعاده الاستقرار الى اليمن بعد ثمان سنوات
من الحرب الدائره هناك
المسارات الدبلوماسيه التي انتهجتها دول
المنطقه صنعت تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سمتها
الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه على صراع السياسي والعسكري
ولقيت اشاده دوليه واماميه
وائل ماسك يقول الان سنزيل في العشرين من
ابريل علامات التحقق الزرقاء بتويتر لمن
لا يدفع الاشتراك مش عارف لا الاداره
بتدفع
تتابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
وا اطباء بريطانيا من القطاع العامه
لمده اربعه ايام للمطالبه برفع اجوره
م
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قطعه محتاجون خطابا
للرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون في لاهاي
ما دفعه للقول ان من لا يحترمون العمليه
الانتخابيه والقاده المنتخبين يعرضون
الديمقراطيه للخطر ورفع ناشطون فرنسيون
لافتات احتجاجيه ضد الرئيس الفرنسي خلال
زياره رسميه له في مملكه هولندا ورفعت
متظاهره لافته تحمل عباره رئيس العنف قبل
ان يتدخل رجال الامن لاخراج السيده من
قاعه مؤسسه نيكسوس حيث القى ماكرون خطابا
تمت مقاطعته من قبل عده محتجين عبروا عن
امتعاضهم من الاحداث الاخيره في فرنسا
وتواجد محتاجون في خارج القصر الملكي في
امستردام اثناء مراسيم الاستقبال الرسميه
ومراسم الاستقبال الرسمي ورفعوا لافتات
تعبر عن انهم لن يتراجعوا
انها
هيمانيتي انا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كشفت مصادر عده عن بدء تزويد الشركات
الروسيه ايران بالنفط مطلع هذا العام عبر
السكك الحديد بعدما فاق استهلاك طهران ما
تنتجه من وقود حيث تسلك شحنات النفط طرقا
عده هذه ابرزها
رغم انتاجها للنفط تتجه ايران الى الوقود
الروسي محكومه بطلاق مصالح مع الحليفه
موسكو لاسيما في العقوبات المفروضه على
البلدين والاستهلاك الذي فاق ما تنتجه من
الوقود المحلي خصوصا في اقاليمها الشماليه
تقول مصادر وبيانات الصادرات ان روسيا
بدات في نقل الوقود الى ايران عبر السكك
الحديديه للمره الاولى في وقت سابق هذا
العام بعدما عزف المشترون التقليديون عن
التجاره مع موسكو اذا زودت موسكو طهران
بما يصل الى 30 الف طن من البنزين والديزل
في فبراير ومارس بحسب المصادر فان الشركات
النفط الروسيه حاليا بدات في تصدير الديزل
والبنزين الى ايران عن طريق السكك
الحديديه والسبب ان الشحن البحري يخضع
لاسعار شحن عاليه ولسقف للاسعار تفرضه دول
مجموعه السبعه النفط الروسي يصل ايران عبر
سكك الحديديه مرورا بكل من قزاخستان
وتركمانستان في حين ان بعض شحنات البنزين
تصل الى دول مجاوره منها العراق عن طريق
الشاحنات امدادات الوقود الروسيه قد تشهد
زياده هذا العام لكنها رهينه بعض المعوقات
على الخطوط لا سيما الخدمات اللوجستيه
وتكدس الحركه المروريه على السكك الحديديه
[موسيقى]
تنفذ الفلبين والولايات المتحده اكبر
مناورات عسكريه مشتركه على الاطلاق في وقت
تتسم فيه العلاقات بين البلدين الحليفين
بالدفء بسبب مخاوفهما المشتركه
طبعا ازاء تزايد نفوذ الصين في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادي ولاول مره ستجري الفلبين
والولايات المتحده تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه
في البحر خلال المناورات التي تستمر ثلاثه
اسابيع تحت اسم ملكتان او كتفا بكثف
[موسيقى]
اصدر موقع جلوبال فاير باور مقارنه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين كقوتين
عسكريتين في ظل الاجواء المشحونه بين
واشنطن وبيكين حول مساله تايوان مقدمات
صار كتير
الولايات المتحده الاولى عسكريا على مستوى
العالم
اما الصين فهي الثالثه
سر التفوق الامريكي يكمن في اربعه عناصر
سلاح الجو والموارد الطبيعيه
القدره اللوجستيه والموقع الجغرافي
سلاح الجو الامريكي يضم
13,300 طائره سلاح الجو الصيني لديه
3248 طائره
بحريا الصين تتفوق على امريكا بعدد السفن
الحربيه
لكن قوه حاملات الطائرات الامريكيه تقلب
المعادله
[موسيقى]
الجيش الامريكي حاضر في اليابان وكوريا
والفلبين والسنغافوره
[موسيقى]
على الجهه المقابله كشفت وسائل الاعلام
حكوميه الصينيه ان تواصل التدريبات
العسكريه حيث استمرت السفن الحربيه
الصينيه في تنفيذ مناوراتها في المناطق
المحيطه بتايوان وياتي هذا التصريح راويه
رغم اعلان الصين في وقت سابق انها انهت
تدريبات استمرت لمده ثلاثه ايام
مناورات الصين ومحاكاه حصار تايوان انتهت
يوم امس لكن اذا ارادت الصين غزوه تايوان
فما سيناريوهات المحتمله يرى محللون
عسكريون ان موقع تايوان الجغرافي كجزيره
مفصوله عن البر الرئيس للصين نقطه قوه
وضعف
في حال حدوث غزو لتايوان يمكن للصين حصار
الجزيره التي تعتمد على اعاده الامداد
والتسلح عبر الجو والبحر واغلاق هذه الطرق
يعتبر خنقا للجزيره ايضا الحصار سيتسبب في
انهاك تايوان اقتصاديا وعسكريا مع بقاء
القوات المسلحه التايوانيه على اهبه
الاستعداد فتره طويله التحليلات تشير الى
ان الصين ستبدا في اي هجوم على تايوان
بالهجوم على الجزر التابعه لها والاقرب
جغرافيا الى البر الصيني مثل جزر ماتسو
وكيمن احتلال بعض او كل هذه الجزر سيكون
بمثابه اعراض قوه للصين واختبارا لمدى
الرغبه الغربيه في مسانده تايوان ودعمها
من الحلول التي قد تلجا اليها الصين
شنهجمات جويه محدوده لاستهداف الدفاعات
الساحليه ومواقع الرادار والمطارات تمهيدا
لهجوم اكبر بعد كسر دفاعات التايوانيه اما
وضع الغزو البري الشامل فسيتم عبر الانزال
البرمائي في نقاط استراتيجيه بعد عبور
مضيق تايوان بسرعه وتحت غطاء من القصف
بالصواريخ والطائرات المقاتله وفضلا عن
الحرب التقليديه من المرجح ان يتم استخدام
الحرب الالكترونيه على نطاق واسع لتعطيل
اتصالات تايوان وبث الذعر بين عامه الناس
[موسيقى]
الى داخل الامريكي فتداعيات تسريبات
الوثائق لا تزال تتوالى عشرات الوثائق
كشفت عن خطط امريكا مستقبلا وكشفت عن
تجسسها على بعض الدول المتابعه
تسريبات من اروقه البنتاجون الى العالم
كشفت عمه تخططه امريكا كما كشفت اختراق
احدى عشر دوله بدءا من الصين الى هايتي في
هذه الوثيقه ما يدل على ان الصين تحت
المجهر تتجسس امريكا على عدوتها اللدود
فهنا وثائق تضمنت تحليلا للمخاطر الصينيه
واسعه النطاق واستعداد بكين لارسال
مساعدات فتاكه الى روسيا وتفاصيل اختبار
تجريبي لصاروخ نووي يفوق سرعه الصوت
تسريبات كشفت ايضا ان امريكا تمارس ضغوطا
على كوريا الجنوبيه في حثها لارسال
مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا في وقت تتخوف
سول من غضب موسكو وثيقه اخرى كشفت مساعيه
اسرائيل لتزويد اوكرانيا بنظام دفاع جوي
سبايدر سام اضافه الى صواريخ جافل المضاده
للدروع بينما يتضح هنا ان روسيا ستزود
ايران بط 35 ونظام دفاع جوي وقدرات
صاروخيه الوثيقه عرجت ايضا على قلق
اسرائيل الشديد من التقارب العسكري بين
روسيا وايران مجموعه باجنال الروسيه
طالتها نار التسريبات ايضا فضحت احدى
الوثائق مخططه فاجنر للسفر الى هايتي
والتعاون رسميا مع عصابات مسلحه متهمه
بقضايا قتل واختطاف مسلسل التسريبات لا
تزال تحليلاته مستمره عالميا ما يضع
الولايات المتحده امام حرج سياسي وعسكري
قد يغير الحسابات مستقبلا غذاء السالم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
ابقاء اللائحه الجمهوريه باقل عدد من
مرشحي الرئاسه هدف للرئيس الامريكي السابق
دون الترامب تحضيرا لانتخابات العام
المقبل يوم امس حاول ترامب ثاني حاكم
فلوريد عن الدخول رسميا في السباق الرئاسي
وقال ان ذلك سيؤدي لتقسيم الحزب الجمهوري
والاضراري بوظيفه ديسانتسكا حاكم وعلى
منصته التروس سوشل كتبت ترامب ان حاكم
فلوريدا لا يبلي بلاء حسنا ضده في
استطلاعات الرايه اضافه ترامب ان ترشح
ديسنتس سيفقده اصوات القاعده الانتخابيه
وانه لن يتمكن ابدا من الترشح لمنصب
الرئاسه بنجاح مره اخرى على حد قول ترامب
بحسب مصادر اعلاميه امريكيه بدات مجموعات
مؤيده لحاكم فلوريدا باستقطاب العديد من
الموظفين الذين عملوا سابقا من الرئيس
السابق ترامب في ادارته او حتى في حملته
كذلك بدا روندي سانتوس بالتوجه الى ولا
التصويت المبكر في الانتخابات التمهيديه
للحزب الجمهوري مثل اي واي وساوت وفي حين
لم يعلن ديسانتس بعد نيته للترشح من عدمه
لكن من المتوقع على نطاق واسع ان يدخل
السباق في الاشهر المقبله قناه فوكس نيوز
كانت الاسبوع الماضي استطلاعا للراي اظهر
ان ترامب يحظى بتاييد
54% من الناخبين من الحزب الجمهوري بينما
جاء ديسنتيس ثانيا بنسبه تاييد وصلت الى
24%
[موسيقى]
تواجه شركه تسلا الامريكيه دعوه قضائيه
بعد اتهامها بالاهمال والاحتيال وانتهاك
الخصوصيه وذلك مع نشر موظفين السابقين
مقاطع مسربه من كاميرات السيارات
الكهربائيه اضارت مشاهد حساسه لا يحق لها
نشرها باي طريقه كانت ولا حتى تداولها
فيما بينهم
السياره الحلم بددت اماني الطواقين
لشرائها لانها باختصار باتت مركبات لا
تؤتمن او ربما خارقه ليس لمواصفاتها فائقه
الجوده فحسب وانما لتسللها الى البيانات
بما فيها الشخصيه
اهمال واحتيال وانتهاك للخصوصيه هذا اقل
ما تواجهه الشركه الامريكيه بعد تقرير
لموظفين سابقين في تسلا يقولون ان عدساتها
انتهكت خصوصيه سائقيها فمثلا اضوائها
الاماميه المحشوه بكاميرا مخفيه لا ترصد
الطرقه وحدها وانما كل التحركات حولها اذا
تواجه تسلا دعوى قضائيه رفعها مجموعه
اشخاص بعد تسريب بعض المقاطع التي احتفظت
بها في قواعدها بعضها لمشاهد حساسه ومحرجه
واوردت الدعوه ان التسجيلات المتداوله
كانت شديده الخصوصيه اظهرت عملاء تسلا في
مواقف قد لا يرغبون في نشرها دون موافقتهم
كل لحظه الحميميه او حتى لحوادث اصطدام
جعلت طفلا يطير وليس انتهاء بتحويل صور
كلابهم الى تعليقات ساخره
ويعود تاريخ هذه التصرفات الى عام 2019
بحسب الدعوه التي نادت بوقف هذا السلوك
الجائر ودفع تعويضات لم تحدد بعد تصرفات
وضعت تسلا في مرمى النيران والمحاكم خاصه
وانها اكدت للملايين من مالكي سياراتها ان
خصوصيتهم كانت وستظل دائما مهمه للغايه
والكاميرات مصممه من الالف الى الياء
لحمايتهم
لا نثق بها ولا نستخدمها بتلك الكلمات عبر
المستاون من تسلا رفاهيه وصفت بالمبتذله
رغم كل ميزاتها التكنولوجيه وحتى صديقتي
للبيئه فهي على حد وصف الواقعين بين فكي
عدساتها الفارهه الجاسوسه وقبل ايام خفضت
للمره الثالثه سعرها ووسعت مصانعها في
شنغهاي لكنها قد لا تستفيد شيئا اذا لم
تداري فضيحه المقاطع المخ جله
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان رائد
سمور الخبير في امن المعلومات اهلا بك سيد
رائد يعني بعد فضيحه تسلا وتسريب هذه
الفيديوهات يعني كيف يمكن ائتمان هذه
السياره على خصوصيتنا يعني ونحن محاطين
اصلا يعني معدات فائقه الذكاء ان كان
بالتلفون اللي كان
بالسياره كان بالحاسوب
نحن نعيش مساء الخير اول شيء مساء النور
نحن نعيش في في تلفزيون الواقع يعني
الحقيقه رغما عن انوفنا اينما ذهبنا هناك
كاميرات ترقب وترصد حركاتنا حتى الان
بالسياره داخل السياره موضوع الخصوصيه
منتهك بشكل كامل
السياره سياره تسلا تحديدا تقوم ببث
معلومات ضخمه جدا خلال الساعه الواحده
تفوق ال 25 جيجا بايت يعني لما بتحسبي
باليوم قديش من الممكن انها تبث معلومات
عن السياره وعن تحرك السياره وعن تشغيل
السياره والسياره وين بتروح وين بتيجي وين
بتتوقف في اي اماكن من الممكن خط السير
اليومي هذه هذه كلياتها انا اعتقد انه لم
يعد هناك اي نوع من انواع الخصوصيه
للانسان على الاطلاق وللاسف يعني احنا
بنقوم بالتوقيع مباشره على شروط الاستخدام
في مثل هذه الحالات يعني حتى من قاموا ومن
ذهبوا الى المحكمه كان موقع بالاساس على
شروط استخدام
نعم مش مش من اجل النشر لكن عمليه التسريب
اللي صارت يعني
كانت رغما عن انف تسلا لانه الموظف غير
مؤتمن الموظفين مجموع الموظفين الموجودين
كانوا غير مؤمنين على هذه الداتا هذه
القسم الخاص هذا هو عباره عن قسم من اجل
تطوير العمل في داخل السياره من اجل تطوير
الخصائص اللي موجوده في السياره
حتى في موظفين سابقين قالوا بانه ممكن
الموضوع يوصل تجسس على يعني مكان اقامه
مالك السياره او على امور اخرى يعني بتقوم
مكان اجهزه استخبارات ولكن ولكن الا ينطبق
ذلك على شركات اخرى لماذا التركيز على
تسلا سيارات الفارهه الحديثه
باهضه باهضه الثمن كلها موصوله بشركات
بالموقع عبر كبسه زر واحده يمكنك ان تصل
الى الشركه في اوروبا وان تتحدث اليهم وان
تحجز موعدا مع gps طبعا مع التليفون مع كل
ما تحدثنا عنه
نعم انا معاك معاك فيما تقوله هناك من
الممكن ان تكون حرف تجاريه ما بين شركات
وتنافس تجاري وما يكون القضايا المرفوعه
هي جزء من التنافس التجاري اللي موجود من
خلال هذه الشركات انا اللي بدي احكيه هذه
انه اي برمجه بشكل كامل فيها كودنج ترتبط
على مربوطه على الانترنت هي قابله
للاختراق وقابله
يعني عمليه مدام كلها موصوله وكلها مرتبطه
بالشركات كيف ممكن انه نحمي خصوصيتنا هل
ذلك ممكن
بدك تجيبش السياره قديمه
بدي اكون
بدي اكون صريح معك وبدي احكيها
واجري على الله يعني نحن ما دمنا ارتضينا
يعني ان نحمل سمارت فون بالبدايه تخلينا
عن 50% من خصوصيتنا ما دمنا نزلنا على هذا
السمارت فون
سوشيال ميديا تخلينا عن 75% ما دمنا
ارتضينا ان يبقى هذا الجهاز مربوط 24 ساعه
على الانترنت فنحن تخلينا عن خصوصيتنا
بشكل كامل هذا على مستوى السمارت فون فما
رايك على مستوى
الكاميرات المراقبه في البيوت على مستوى
كاميرات المراقبه في الشوارع على مستوى
الكاميرات الخاصه داخل السيارات فنحن احنا
الان ايضا الخدمات التي تقدم في المقابل
لا اعتقد انه في احد يمكن يريد ان يعيش
حياه العصر اليوميه يمكن ان يستغني عنها
واعتقد حضرتك ايضا استاذ رائد طبعا ذلك
انا انا اول المستخدمين الى سيدي
يعني المفروض على الاقل كخبير عن
المعلومات لازم تكون كل يوم عم تجرب كل شي
جديد شو اكثر شيء فاجئك
طبيعه عملنا تدعونا الى ذلك دائما وابدا
شو اكثر شيء بفاجئك بطبيعه عملنا تدعونا
الى ذلك بالجانب التجسسيه بهالمعنى هيدا
شو اكثر شي بفاجئك ويثير لديك الاسئله
يمكن ان نشارك المشاهدين فيها
والله حقيقه يعني الان العصر الذكاء
الاصطناعي وانا اعتقد انه هذا ما يثير
الاهتمام الان بشكل اكبر وبشكل كبير جدا
الاعتداء على خصوصيه الانسان وصلت الى
مرحله يعني كنا اول اشي على مستوى داتا
على مستوى ايش بتنشر على مستوى مين صديقك
ايش اهتماماتك الان اصبحنا يعني كان
التواصل من ديفايس لديفايس من شبكه الى
شبكه انا اعتقد انه مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
وصلنا الى مرحله اخطر من هذه بكثير وصلنا
الى مرحله الانسن الرقميه بمعنى ربط
البرين على ديفايس فعمليا مرحله الشعور
الانساني اللي كانت محرمه على اي شيء فيها
خصوصيه وفيها قداسه انا اعتقد الان هي
تنتهك وان مرحله الذكاء الاصطناعي تخطت
هذه المساله ووصلنا الى مرحله انه حتى على
مرحله الشعور الانساني اصبحنا مهددين
بانتها على مرحله الشعور الانساني
مهددين اصبحنا
نعم احنا مهددين عمليا عمليا الان اجهزه
الذكاء الاصطناعي تعمل على على موضوع
برينتو برينكو او برينتو ديفايسون فعمليا
اهتماماتنا على مستوى الشعور الانساني
يعني
لكن
الاهتمام على مستوى هذا الشعور الانساني
ان يدخل الى الخلايا العصبيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي ويتعامل مع مات قد تشعر في
بمعنى انه حتى عمليا العاطفي من الممكن ان
تنقلها عبر الخلايا العصبيه
عبر الذكاء الاصطناعي فعمليا التداخل في
هذه وتوقع الذكاء الاصطناعي ما هي العاطفه
من الممكن ان تعيشها على مدار الساعه انا
اعتقد هذا هذا انتهاك كبير جدا
لخصوصيتنا وانت اعطيك مثل بسيط جدا على
مستوى
الجسد الانساني الساعه اللي بتلبسيها اللي
مربوطه على على
هذه الساعه بتعد بتعد نبضات القلب بتعد
قديش بتاكلي بتعد قديش بتمشي بتعد كل شيء
فما رايك بمرحله اذا هذه ساعه مرحله
الذكاء الاصطناعي تتعدى هذا بشكل كبير جدا
احنا وصلنا الى مرحله يعني
ما في خصوصيه على الاطلاق مثل ما ذكرت سيد
رائد يعني
فيجب ان نقبل التكنولوجيا بحسناتها
وسيئاتها شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات رائد سمور الخبير في امن
المعلومات حدثنا من عمان شكرا لك استاذ
رائد
[موسيقى]
بدا لف الاطباء في المملكه المتحده يمثلون
النصف اطباء القطاع العام اضرابا مدته
اربعه ايام للمطالبه باجور افضل في خضم
ازمه غلا معيشه ووصف القائمون على النظام
الصحي التعبئه بانها الاشد تاثيرا في
تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه في بريطانيا دعينا
البريطانيين الى تجنب التصرفات الخطيره
لان النظام الصحي غير قادر على توفير
العنايه اللازمه
شيرين مواطنه بريطانيه تلقت رساله هذا
الصباح من خدمه الصحه الوطنيه تبلغها
بتاجيل موعدها حتى يوليو المقبل ما يعني
انها ستضطر الى تحمل الم تعاني منه منذ
سنوات في عمودها الفقري املها الا يتسبب
الانتظار بتفاقم وضعها الصحي
تلقيت رساله هذا الصباح تبلغني ان موعدي
تاجل حتى نهايه يوليو ما يعني اني ساتحمل
الالم لبضعه اشهر اخرى وقد تزداد المشكله
سوءا الغاء موعد شيرين من ضمن 350 الف
موعد طبي ملغى او مؤجل لاشخاص سيتاثرون
بالاضات المستمره حتى عطله نهايه الاسبوع
المطالب رفع الاجور بنسبه 35% نسبه قالت
النقابات انها تاخذ بالاعتبار السنوات
الخمسه عشره الاخيره التي لم تشهد زياده
عادله نسبه ترفضها الحكومه وترى انها غير
واقعيه
[موسيقى]
التقينا بالسيد باركلي مرتين حتى الان في
المره الاولى لم يكن لديه اي تفويض
لمناقشه الاجور اما المره الثانيه التي
التقينا به لم يقدم لنا عرضا بل وخرج من
المفاوضات
الهدف بالنسبه للاطباء ليس انيا وانما في
طياته بعد نظر قبل انهيار القطاع الصحي
بالكامل اذا ظل كما هو الان
هذه الاضرابات ضروريه لتحسين الوضع الصحي
على الرغم من انها تتسبب بازمه على المدى
القصير لكن امل حقا ان يفهم المرضى اننا
نفعل ذلك ليس فقط من اجلنا ولكن ايضا من
اجلهم
الدكتور احمد هو الاخر من مرضى القلب
الذين يقيمون في بريطانيا منذ عام 82 ياسف
على تغير حال القطاع الصحي في البلاد
كمريض قلب مباشره
بيقطعوا كل شيء وبياخذوني لجوا ويحطوني
فاما الناس الثانيين يا حرام عما ينتظروا
كتير ساعات وساعات
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يضرب فيها
هؤلاء الاطباء لكن فتره الاضراب الطويله
ستتسبب في تاخير مواعيد المرضى الذين
يعانون بالاساس من لوائح انتظار عليها
اكثر من سبعه ملايين مريض من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
في العربيه 360 ايضا وايضا في الحرم المكي
اجهزه رصد الانطباعات تعمل بالذكاء
الاصطناعي نتعرف عليها مع مراسلنا من هناك
بعد الفصل ارجو ان تقوم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت بعثه الامم
المتحده في افغانستان انها باتت امام خيار
صعب جراء قرار طالبان منع النساء
الافغانيات من العمل مع المنظمه الدوليه
مباشره البعثه الى ان قرار الحركه سيعقد
مواصله العمليات الدوليه في افغانستان
وطلبت من موظفيها الافغان عدم الذهاب الى
مكاتبهم قبل يوم الخميس من مايو المقبل
وجاء في بيان لبعثت الامم المتحده في
افغانستان ان سلطات طالبان تسعى الى ارغام
الامم المتحده على الاختيار بين الالتزام
بقوانين الحركه او البقاء وتوفير دعم
للشعب الافغاني واكدت الامم المتحده في
بيانها ان رئيسه البعثه روزا اوتون بشره
مراجعه عمل مراجعات عملياتيه لتحديد
الخطوات المقبله وبحسب البعثه يجب على
سلطات طالبان ان تتحمل اي عواقب سلبيه
لهذه الازمه على الشعب الافغاني
[موسيقى]
اعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي فتحه تحقيق في
سرقه مساعدات غذائيه تم توزيعها خلال
العمليات الانسانيه في مناطق النزاع في
اثيوبيا واضاف البرنامج ان المساعدات
المسروقه تم العثور على جزء كبير منها في
اسواق المواد الغذائيه
التحقيق في سرقه وبيع مساعدات انسانيه في
اثيوبيا برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابع
للامم المتحده فتح تحقيقا حول عدم وصول
المساعدات المستحقيها وظهورها في الاسواق
مدير البرنامج في اثيوبيا قال ان ظهور
المساعدات في بعض الاسواق خطر على سمعه
البرنامج ويهدد قدرته على جمع مزيد من
الموارد من اجل المحتاجين
على ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات فوريه للحد من
اختلاس وسرقه المساعدات الانسانيه في
البلاد فرع برنامج الغذاء في اثيوبيا طالب
المنظمات الشريكه بالابلاغ عن اي معلومات
تتعلق باساءه استخدام الطعام او اختلاسه
برنامج الاغذيه لم يحدد حالات معينه لكن
عمال اغاثه اشاروا الى ان المساعدات سرقت
من بلده شيرارو وتضمنت ما يكفي من الطعام
لمئه الف شخص
[موسيقى]
تشهد اروقه المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه
تطورا كبيرا في استخدام اجهزه تعتمد على
تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي وذلك لرست
انطباعات ضيوف الرحمن وزوار المعارض
الرمضانيه بالمسجد الحرام بطريقه تفاعليه
من خلال حركه اليد للتعبير عن مدى الرضا
وتعمل الاجهزه بست لغات عالميه كما تتميز
بامكانيه التعرف على جنس الاشخاص وعمر من
اجروا التقييم اضافه لربط الانطباعات بحسب
رحله ضيوف الرحمن والخدمات المقدمه لهم
وايضا الرصد المباشر وتحليل الانطباعات
واظهارها بشكل فوري على شاشه العرض
وانضم الينا من مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه
اسامه القاسم اهلا بك معنا الليله اسامه
يعني انطباعات وتفاعل ضيوف الرحمن الرحمن
حول الشاشات والاجهزه التي تستعمل الذكاء
الاصطناعي ونحن نرى وراءك يعني شاشات
كبيره تعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي الرقمي
اهلا وسهلا الراويه اهلا الطاهر تحيه طيبه
لكما ولجميع مشاهدينا العربيه انقل لكم
الصوت والصور اليوم مجددا من هنا من معرض
كسوه الكعبه المشرفه في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه التي تشمل هذه اللوحه التي
نشاهدها الان عبر الكاميرا العربيه هذه
اللوحه تحت مسمى من الوصول الى الحصول هي
معرض رقمي يتيح للزائر وقاصد بيت الله
الحرام التعرف على مناطق المسجد الحرام
وايضا قراءه القران وعدد من التعليمات
المتواجده في جميع مناطق الحرم المكي اما
هذه الشاشه فهي شاشه تقنيه تتيح لاي زائره
ومعتمر اختيار المسجد الذي يريده ثم يدخل
على اي خيار من هذه الخيارات اني اختار
مثلا اهتمامات الزائر المعتمر هنا نجد عدد
من الاشياء والخطوات التي يختارها الزائر
او المقتصد بيت الله الحرام ليختار كل هذه
الامور هنا مثلا مناسك العمره ليجد بان
جميع المناسك متواجده في هذه المنطقه بعده
لغات اترككم الان في جوله عبر الكاميرا
العربيه حول هذه المنطقه وهي تحوي قطعه
اثريه قديمه
لكسوه الكعبه المشرفه كهذه الثقالات التي
تم تثبيت الكسوه الكسوه الكعبه المشرفه في
العهد السعودي هذه ايضا المناطق التي
نشهدها والقطع الاثريه التي تشهدها هذه
المعارض هذه اللوحه التي نشاهدها الان
عمرها اكثر من 30 عام وهي كسوه تعود لعام
1414 للهجره هذه ايضا حلقات من النحاس
كانت تثبت بها الكسوه في العهد السعودي
هنا ايضا مجسم مصغر لباب الكعبه المشرفه
ومجسم باب الكعبه المشرفه بكل الادعيه
واذكار الموجوده في هذه المجسمات هنا ايضا
العود الذي يبخر به الحرم المكي الشريف
وهو عود خالص هنا ايضا عدد من العده
وادوات غسيل الكعبه من الداخل التي
نشاهدها الان والتي ترعاها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين واخيرا هذه الاطياب الخاصه التي
تعطر بها الكعبه المشرفه وايضا الحجر
الاسود والملتزم والركن اليماني اما هنا
ايضا فاتحدث عن التجربه لاي زائر وقاصد
لبيت الله الحرام ليتحدث وايضا يعمل على
خياطه كسوه الكعبه المشرفه كخطوه تجريبيه
تتيحها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين جميع المعدات
والادوات التي تعمل بها كسوه الكعبه
المشرفه اما هنا فهذه التقنيه التي تحدثنا
عنها هي تقنيه كيف يقيس زوار وقاصدين بيت
الله الحرام رضا المستفيدين من هذه الشاشه
نشاهد الان كما نشاهد عبر الكاميرا ان
الزائر والمعتمر سيتواجد امام هذه المنطقه
ثم من يقوم بعمل هذه الحركه لاثبات رضا او
العكس كذلك بسته لغات متواجده في هذه
اللوحه كل هذه الخدمات التي تتحدث عنها
اليوم هنا في الحرم والتحديد في التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه لتكون هذه الت تجربه
اثريه لقاصد وزائر بيت الله الحرام نتحدث
اليوم ايضا بما اننا تحدثنا عن الخدمات
المقدمه نتحدث عن الخدمات المتواجده الى
يومنا هذا الاستقبال المصلين والمعتمرين
لمسجد البيت الله الحرام وفي التحديد في
العشر الاواخر نتحدث انه اليوم بحول الله
تعالى سوف تكون هناك تبدا صلاه القيام من
اليوم نتحدث ايضا عن اعداد الزوار
المعتمرين الذين تجاوزوا الى هذه اللحظه
حوالي 19 مليون زائره ومعتمر اعلنت
الرئاسه ان عدد الزوار والمعتمرين الذين
ياتون كل يوم يتجاوزون 950 الف معتبر
مشاهدينا ايضا كل هذه الاعداد الغفيره
وهذه الوفود لياتوا لتجربه هذا المكان
وايضا ان يعيشوا تجربه مثاليه في هذه
المنطقه شكرا جزيلا شكرا سامر قاسم مراسل
العربيه من مكه المكرمه تحياتي اليك شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 راويه
الذي وجه نداء الى زوجته ميلانيا وكشفت
المصادر ان ترامب واجهها لميلانيا نداء
جاء فيه انا بحاجه اليك لاننا سنقوم بحمله
المصادر نقلت ان الزوجين اجريا حديثا
رئيسا خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع ووافقت على
الانضمام اليها
فيديو اليوم هو بواسطه كاميرات المراقبه
اكتشف امام تركي سرقه المال من صندوق
تبرعات المسجد في عمليه تمت لاكثر من مره
في مدينه سامسونج الساحليه الواقعه على
البحر الاسود يبدا على اثرها على الفور
بتقديم شكوى للشرطه في المدينه التي تمكنت
من القاء القبض على اللص
وبدا مقطع الفيديو الذي سجلته كاميرات
المراقبه صادما بعدما اظهر ان اللصه تظاهر
بالصلاه بعدما انتبه احدهم اليه وهو يحاول
فتح صندوق التبرعات بواسطه سلك حديدي
وعندما كان المسجد خاليا من الناس
ان نشاهد في الصور
وهكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 ولكن
ننتقل الى اسامي صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه
وملفات جديده مساء الخير مساء الخير مساء
النور راويه وطاهر على راس هذه الملفات
قرار ايلون ماسك الذي امهل اصحاب العلامه
الزرقاء على تويتر حتى العشرين من شهر
ابريل الجاري والا سيحرمون من العلامه
بعرف اذا سمعنا
كذلك
بعد قليل يفسر لنا ما الاجراءات
سالته لطاهر اذا دفع انت دفعت انا والله
لسه بعد لم يصلني اي اشعار على الاقل
لنرى لنرى بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات